where did Matthew McConaughey
get all right oh where did he get off
get all right all right all right first
film I'm ever on days confused I'm in
the car about to do my first scene ever
on film it's non-scripted and it was a
scene that's in the movie where
wooderson's hanging out in front of the
pool hall girls walk by he reaches over
slaps one on the backside his buddy says
you got to cut that out or you got to go
to jail and he steps forward says no man
that's what I love about those high
school girls I get older but they stay
the same age so that line I'm like who
is this guy right yeah I wouldn't mind
about what am I about to myself and all
of a sudden I hear action and I look up
and I look at Marissa robisie across the
way into myself I got the fourth thing
worse than about is picking up chicks
all right all right all right
first words that was that on screen